hello internet i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report and we have
a young turks all-star edition anna
casparian
jimmy dore we didn't even need a third
person because of the
breadth of your knowledge and egos do
you normally have a third person
we normally have a third person oh okay
well i'll talk double you can do two
people you can do impressions whatever
you want to do
all right sounds i'll you know once in a
while jank will come in
and i'll just impersonate him jen can
jump in all right
welcome to the young turks
awesome yeah well you guys know how it
works and you're comfortable at this
table
so here we go all right first story uh
north korea uh you know by the time this
story
gets up on youtube we could have been
decimated in a nuclear war they
are uh threatening to preemptively
strike us they are moving
uh people out of the embassies they want
diplomats out of the country
by april 10th it is a big mess but we
sort of think it feels a little
jokey to me what do you guys think what
do we do
about this north korea madness i think
that at this point
it's common knowledge that north korea
doesn't have the nuclear capabilities
necessary to actually attack the united
states
they've been threatening the united
states for quite a while now the
question is are they going to attack
south korea
and of course that's entirely possible
um
north korea is not a rational actor as
it was as we all know so if there is a
possibility that this is going to end
badly
but the question is what should the role
be of the united states at this point
and any experience i've had in the past
is when the u.s gets involved in
something
internationally it doesn't end well
nothing good right
never comes out of it and the reason why
north korea is threatening the u.s to
begin with is because they don't like
some of the military exercises that
u.s soldiers are doing with south korean
soldiers military jumping jacks
yeah they don't like the jumping jacks
they're very uh offended by that it's uh
intimidating
yeah so um i i don't know what the us is
gonna do i just hope that they don't act
prematurely and do something stupid
jimmy do you consider prematurely
something i know about yeah
do you consider kim jong-un an
irrational actor okay uh i consider mel
gibson to be an irrational actor
kim jong-un you know i to me the funnest
part about this whole story was that it
got started with dennis rodman
yeah going over there and people were
upset with him because
and you know i thought he was perfect
ambassador material
but uh turns out he wasn't and then he
went on george knuffle up against the
show
and he held his he was like do you what
about his um
his human rights violations and dennis
ramon is like sitting there with
sunglasses on
huh what are you talking about played
basketball and he said don't you feel
like you have a responsibility to ask
him about that
you know the toughest question i
expected dennis rodman to ask is is this
north or south korea
yeah that's what i expected yeah isn't
this though isn't this part of the
problem that we
dennis rodman's over there kim jong-un
looks the way he looks like it all seems
this seems like a movie it doesn't seem
real so when they're like oh we're going
to preemptively nuclear strike you
whether they can or can't
it seems made up this seems silly
doesn't it it sounds silly especially
when we know
you know some of the crazy behavior of
the you know dictator of north korea
how crazy his father was i mean
anonymous
did something that i found hilarious
they hacked into their intranet
because they're not really part of the
internet um and uh
yeah and i just like the word intro i do
i do like that
and uh they had like a webpage
where they had a picture of uh un uh
with
a mickey mouse tattoo on his stomach of
course they photoshopped it and like pig
ears and like a pig nose and it was
hilarious so like
the entire thing even though their
threats seem serious and they sound
scary
i mean people have handled it in such a
funny way the way anonymous has handled
it
was hilarious so i think that's part of
the reason why no one's really taking
the threats that seriously
i really don't take them seriously at
all i can't believe anyone would so he
so then he launches a nuclear missile
what's his next move right right then
his country's over
right so it it will it will not that's
why it's funny to hear
uh like people uh who's the news defense
secretary i'm blanking out his name uh
uh robert gates no that's the old one no
uh rob
you're right that is the other one uh
chuck hagel there you go so he was
talking like this
this time it's serious and we're all i'm
like really this time i don't understand
why they pretended like it was serious
yeah he's never gonna do anything is
there any
part of you that empathizes a little bit
with north korea because why do we have
30
000 troops right on their border where
flying b 52 is like forget
all the intricacies that we don't we're
not really privy to
but a little bit of we have a military
why do we have 30 000 troops
uh right next door to them because
they're crazy
that [ __ ] craze right like look i look i
know that
part of the reason why there's a lot of
hostility toward the united states is
because we love to go into other
countries when we have no business being
there
and uh you know we love to meddle in
their business but at the same time
north korea has been threatening us for
quite a while so i could understand why
the us would want to have some sort of
military presence
on the border um but you know at the
same time like i definitely don't think
the us
should like invade north korea any time
soon or do anything crazy
um i i i don't even think that the us
should get too involved with
uh you know the conflict with south
korea and north korea because
that's what we always do we love to take
a side and then when we take a side
there's hostility toward the united
states because of the side that we've
taken
of course jimmy final word when does the
war begin
there's no war it's not going to happen
you know getting back to that other
point about why are we even there i just
think it's because once we're somewhere
we never leave anywhere right we're
still in japan we're still in germany we
have 30 000 troops or 70 000 troops in
germany yes germany germany i was there
i was like this is not you guys have a
nice place here and they have
they have the u.s military has their own
huge airport they have their home it's
i'm like right in the middle of another
country it's weird what are we doing
there is it really just because the
military
industrial complex is so big and it's
like we're just never going to take
these people home
never going to take them home they have
hospitals there they have i mean
american bases i mean it's really
it's nice over there yeah all right well
let's move on to the gays because we
can't go as day
in america without talking about the
homosexuals as bill o'reilly
calls him uh it's actually been a pretty
good week for the gays again
because uh two more senators this week
democratic senators have now
endorsed marriage equality uh we got
heidi heitkamp that's not a made-up name
and uh senator joe donnelly they jumped
in
also a couple uh republican senators for
the first time jumped in this week so
the only four
democratic senators left that are
against marriage equality are joe
manchin of west virginia mary landrieu
of louisiana mark pryor of arkansas
and tim johnson of south dakota so i
guess we'll start
are these four is this all politics at
this point like is this just
are they all having real revelations and
are they really evolving or is this
purely
partisan politics and you got to get on
board with the democratic team
no i think it's good like a guy like joe
manchin holding out you know
for the he's representing that part of
america who still
thinks gayness is gross so good for him
that's really all it comes down to it's
right it's like this old antiquated
thinking and the knee
and it's just even um you know a lot of
religious people now
are um they're not they're on board with
it they get that it's not
something who would choose i know the
whole thing about choice
is what frustrates me the most i think a
lot of people out there that are bigots
are
the way that they are because of
ignorance right they genuinely think
that this is like perversion
and that gay people make that decision
at some point in their lives and they
have some sort of
illness and and all you have to really
do is sit down and educate people and
let them know what the reality is
and when it comes to these democratic
representatives
at the end of the day no one wants to be
on the wrong side of history you know i
was talking to megan mccain and we were
tweeting you know
not a big deal we're twitter friends um
yeah yeah and
look megan mccain has some politics that
i don't agree with but the one thing
that i love is she has been an outspoken
supporter of gay rights
and uh you know she said you know one
day when i have kids i'm going to be
proud to say that i was on the right
side of history
and i feel the exact same way and i hope
that these representatives feel the same
way are some of them doing it for
politics
absolutely and i think that that's lame
i think sometimes you have to stand up
for
what you truly believe in as opposed to
playing politics isn't it crazy that at
this point let's say these four in their
heart of hearts really don't think gay
people are that evil but they played
that card to get voted in
that they could potentially now be voted
out because they're gonna
do the right thing isn't that doesn't
that just show how crazy politics really
is
um well it shows how kind of maybe
backward their own individual states are
you know the rural states seem to be the
ones that are tough to come along and so
wherever people bump up against other
people it seems like progression
happens right that's where progressives
come from cities and it's just
and that's i think kind of shines a
light on what's wrong with the way we
are not only our whole political system
that people
in states that have no people living in
it have just as much power
as states that have elect so it's it's
not one man one vote in america
and i think that we need to take a lo i
mean i don't know if you can ever take
away someone's representation
but it's weird that you would have two
senators and one congressman right
that's not right so you're saying that
the senator from uh montana where they
have seven people shouldn't be quite as
powerful as the guy from i think barbara
boxer let's say here in california
that's exactly what i'm saying yes
yeah uh i'm i'm interested in i would be
nice if we had a parliamentary
you know kind of government here instead
of the one we do i think we'd get more
stuff done like canada
yeah by the way canada's had gay
marriage and uh their their country then
hasn't crumbled yet
yeah and don't you love how every time
something good happens in america like
we get healthcare
all the lunatics say well i'm going to
move to canada where they have
healthcare yeah
we're going to have gay marriage here
i'm moving to canada where they have gay
marriage it just shows you how really
dumb these people are
but what do you think about is there
going to be a point where it's too late
so like these four democrats that are
left like can we just give them like a
cut-off date like you have till
wednesday yeah
and then after that you're not getting
any credit whether you do it or not you
know what i mean like i feel like we
need some sort of cut off
otherwise we're just dragging these
people for all the wrong reasons i feel
uncomfortable
giving them credit now because if you
were an opponent
of marriage equality or you know even
gay acceptance for instance if you were
an
opponent of that how do you just like
evolve on that issue so freaking quickly
so i'm not buying that i mean i think
that probably in their heart of hearts
they do
believe in uh marriage equality uh for
gay people
but i just hate that they played the
politics and it makes me not want to
give them any credit
politicians playing politics is there
anything worse i can't i'm
gambling i um but i will
you know talk about not giving people
credit you know uh i thought it was
funny to hear before the election people
said we have to vote for barack obama
because he
he came out for gay rights he only only
took the first black president three and
a half years to realize
that we shouldn't discriminate against
groups of people right wow don't break
your arm patting yourself on the back
there mr obama right and he basically
only did it because he got sort of
cornered into it yes
on me so that's so it's it's weird to
see people
um especially someone who's an
african-american
who should be more sensitive to that
issue still play politics with you i'm
gonna pander to the people who are
bigoted for a little while
and then i'm gonna i'm not gonna do
anything gay rights among the
african-american community
is a very touchy subject as well because
a lot of black people are conservative
they're religious
so uh even though it i totally believe
it is a civil rights issue
you know some black individuals don't
see it that way well there's a therapist
here's the whole dl
phenomenon where these guys are secretly
gay
and you know it's not accepted but
they're doing it you know
the dl hughley syndrome i think it's
called that if we just outed him
but don't you think it's funny that they
like some people think it's like well
you know i think the state should vote
on it it's like
you shouldn't vote on something yeah how
about i think if we voted on regular
marriage i don't know if that would pass
either
exactly or if we had ever voted onto
interracial marriage that
you know or people being allowed to vote
the minority should not
be subjected to the vote of the majority
in fact
when when they got rid of the law
banning uh interracial marriage
only 25 percent of the country backed
that so they they went against the will
of the country to do to enforce the
constitution which is nice to see they
do that
sometimes absolutely final point on this
do you do you think there's a little bit
of a risk in that we put so much focus
uh on social issues in politics like
there's so many important things going
on with the economy
and north korea and all that stuff and
yet so much of our media is just driven
by the social stuff do you think that's
an act there's actual risk
in that in terms of the discourse i'm a
little biased because i
do an entire hour of social commentary
news
but i will say that um i do think that
it's extremely important
because this has a lot to do with
liberty and personal liberties
so um we have to cover the social news
because we have to make sure that
there's equality for all groups of
people
if if there is a case of like for
instance uh we just recently did a story
about
a high school in georgia that has never
had a racially
integrated prom they've they've had
segregated proms
all these years even after brown v the
board of education i mean it's insane
and so it's important to talk about
those things because you want to make
sure you protect people's rights
um and when it comes to uh you know
marriage equality
it's we're starting to see progress and
part of the reason why we're seeing
progress is because we're shining a
bright
light on this issue and i'm biased
also because i don't like armenians but
the point is
i don't know what we've been talking
about now okay then then that will be
the end of that one
okay uh but let's keep going with
politics for a little bit uh the
president actually had to
issue an apology just a couple days ago
uh he had to apologize
uh to kamala harris uh who
is the california attorney general and
he
well he called her the quote the best
looking attorney general
and then women's groups were up in arms
because you know this is
sexualizing her and they've worked so
hard to gain equality etc etc
i feel i must start with the woman here
to me this seems a little
uh there's something a little
disingenuous about this because
everyone wants to be appreciated for how
they look if they look good
you want to get credit for that he said
you look good he didn't say oh that
dumpy woman
over there you know what i mean so i
take it away i love this topic
um and you know just so you guys know
the full context
um he prefaced it by basically telling
her
how incredibly accomplished strong
intelligent she is
he he said everyone in the room has has
to watch out for her because she's so
great this and that
i have not all here i just didn't want
to focus yeah i was getting ready yeah
no but i think that it's important to
put it in context because
had he just said hey everyone kamala
harris she's super hot like let's
give her a round of applause like that's
different that's belittling her
accomplishments
but in that case he basically called her
the full package like
she's intelligent she's accomplished
she's everything that you could possibly
want
and she's attractive and honestly if
someone had said that to me if the
president of the united states had said
that to me
i would lose it like in a good way like
good luck like i would be
so unbelievably flattered so i get it i
get that feminists
don't want um women the accomplishments
of
women to be belittled but i don't think
that's what he was doing here yeah and
also they've
now shown many clips where he's given
awards to men where he says oh this is
the best looking guy in the room or look
how handsome he is or he's awful tall
look at his hair
yeah what do you think first of all that
was that was a great breakdown anna and
you are beautiful when you break
something
well thank you i am good at breaking
things down um
you know it's really i talk i get that
you don't want to sexualize a woman
especially you know in that kind of
setting
yeah and you don't want to but you know
at the same time you can't take the boy
out of the thing and the thing out of
the boy right so he's still going to be
a human being and she is attractive and
it's like so we have to pretend that
isn't going
on um i i don't know it's i'm not a
woman and it's tougher
in the workplace for a woman than it is
for a man so i don't really know what to
say about it but all i can know is that
it
it makes men it's that that's when you
get that remember they would just talk
about the white guy backlash
right so that's like so now i can't even
tell a woman she's pretty
kind of what is this russia you know so
that's it gets that kind of thing
stirring up in men
i'm saying something nice and i'm
getting in trouble for saying there's
nothing i can do so it starts to make
certain men feel like they're damned if
they do and they're damned if they don't
yeah
yeah and and so an interesting thing has
happened
in society that i i'm not like too happy
about
and i know that a lot of women are
comfortable with this they would prefer
to have it this way
but sometimes i like getting a
compliment about the way i look for my
male peers you know
and i wouldn't be offended by it but a
lot of women out there would be offended
by it
so like sometimes when i put extra
effort like i'm like you know what i'm
going to really
really focus on the blush today or
whatever it is you know
i like i like it when someone notices
and says like hey ed i noticed your hair
cut but
it's crazy because we've created an
environment now where
guys are afraid to tell women that
they're attractive and
i i don't think that that was what the
goal was in the beginning the goal was
to
prevent sexual harassment from guys like
grabbing you and saying things that were
degrading to you yeah how much of this
do you think is just because we have
these advocacy groups
you know there's women's advocacy groups
there's you know glad for gays there's
peta all this stuff
where they just they're in the business
of having to wrangle feathers otherwise
they're out of business i mean it really
is a money thing for them too they they
sort of had to say something about this
because this is their bread and butter
kind of ironic that peter was ruffling
feathers
but even then rush limbaugh says it's
the gay mafia who's turning and you know
the gay mafia
oh yeah they make you an offer you can't
refuse because it's so fabulous
right they give you the kiss to death
they use tongue and a reach around come
on
oh wow wow i know i've got jokes ready
we need a rim shot thank you bro hey
watch your mom my goodness
i walked right into this this is a clean
show clean show all right well i think
we i think we
yeah clear that one up right yeah so uh
but that again if that's another
you kind of uh you get to
backlash against the good thing you're
trying to do and then it gets bad gets
turned into a negative thing which is
weird
yeah do you think we just live in this
overly apologetic society i mean is it
crazy at the president i know he just
sort of he didn't have to apologize here
but he did
he just came out and did it immediately
just to end this thing but is it sad
that we
just said don't you think that that
diminishes when there really is
um yes sex sexual harassment i think it
diminishes the thing that's
that's like so now when someone is
actually aggrieved
or somebody does something wrong now
it's going to be kind of
in a gray area because well he just said
she was pretty is it one of those things
yeah and the irony i think in this
particular case with obama we've never
had a president and a first lady who so
much of their image is
it really is based on how they look
she's beautiful they're always seen in
perfect clothes perfectly smiling you
know
they have their own press core basically
that releases all the official
pictures of them so so much of it is
based in looks and then he made one
little
silly comment but uh i think it hurts
feminism
i agree with you 100 i think that when
you take situations like for instance
seth macfarlane at the oscars and you
say that seth macfarlane is sexist
that belittles actual cases of sexism
that is not a case of sexism and i think
that this is another example of that
he couldn't have complimented her in a
better way he talked about all of her
accomplishments
he really emphasized that and then in
the very end he said
she's good looking yeah big deal jimmy
you're right she's very pretty when she
makes a point
okay nice blush thank you
let's uh let's stick with the president
so he decided uh this week to give back
five percent of his salary because of
the sequester he thought that would be a
nice uh
little gesture to the furloughed workers
uh and
uh five percent of his four hundred
thousand dollar a year salary
is about twenty thousand bucks john
kerry the secretary of state also did it
now he only makes a cool
180 000 a year uh so that was about nine
thousand bucks now he's worth
you know he's married to teresa hines
ketchup you can't get ketchup in this
country
without going through john kerry he's
worth about 200 million bucks
gave 9 000 so are things like this is
at the state department free ketchup for
life or something that would have been
more worthy
than 9 000 i mean are these things just
silly little tokens yes
and it's just nothing more than that
yeah like let's deal with the economy
let's uh
get rid of corporate tax loopholes like
if obama was actually a fighter
in in terms of raising revenue through
taxing the rich
you know their fair share of taxes and
getting rid of these ridiculous
deductions that wealthy people get to
take advantage of
then i would give him like a round of
applause but this is like okay
so you're giving up twenty thousand
dollars a year who cares you're still
tremendously wealthy does
does the uh carry one seem worse to you
because
of how much he's worth i mean nine
thousand bucks
uh well he but he was uh he was against
giving back the money before he was four
so just so you know yeah um what why i
think while they're why they're doing
this is because
whoever whichever political party gets
tagged with
the most of the responsibility for the
sequester as these cuts
actually start to be felt which they're
starting to be felt now
uh so that's why they're doing a c look
we're the good guys it's the sequester
isn't our fault and that's why the
republicans keep saying
do president obama wanted this this is
his idea it was his idea
and um so they're all trying to try to
get to get away from this they're trying
to
get distance from it and this is the way
barack obama's administration has
decided
see we're not even we're taking the cut
too we're with you we're with the people
not like the other
and but do people fall for that because
it strikes me as such a disingenuous
thing i mean the money means nothing to
him he obviously is not walking around
day to day pulling any cash out of his
pocket and spending a dime
so it seems disingenuous but you think
there's just the pr yes it's just it is
i mean it's you know most a lot of the
stuff that happens in washington is some
you know politically symbolic and it's
but it's also important i think it is
important to show that hey we're with
you we're not ignoring that you guys are
hurting
but uh it but it is barack obama's fault
i mean
people it is his fault because we should
have never had the sequester in the
first place because
he should have never caved to those
idiots in the first place when they said
they weren't going to raise the debt
ceiling
and by negotiating over that he said a
horrible precedent well now he says he's
not getting any more
i already screwed up bad enough so i'm
not going to do that again
yeah you sound like bob woodward uh-huh
do i okay
i think he's setting a terrible
precedent right now with the grand
bargain i mean the the gop has basically
rejected the grand bargain
but obama is basically saying you know
what i want to increase revenue so it's
increased taxes on the wealthy but i'm
totally willing to make cuts to social
security and medicare which are called
entitlement programs
because we are freaking entitled to it
we've paid into that system
we shouldn't be cutting it at all that
shouldn't even be on the table there's
no they're not drivers of the debt
right exactly social security has its
own trust fund right you know and
medicare also solvent until 2023 by the
way so
this is this is all manufactured these
are just people who don't like social
programs and then barack obama gives
credence to it
and goes along with it so yeah do you
think part of the problem is that we
just go
from crisis to crisis that we don't have
any we clearly have no long you know we
had a fiscal cliff that no one had even
heard of the phrase fiscal cliff
until the fiscal cliff happened two
weeks before and then once it hashtagged
on twitter everyone knew what it was
and then the sequester which no one had
heard of the sequester like we just do
this we manufacture these things and
then
and it's the way that we actually get
nothing done but everyone just screams
about it all the time
absolutely and it's it's this cycle that
i just cannot handle anymore like it's
to the point where
you know that it's an important topic
you want to pay close attention to it
because it has to do with your
livelihood as a member of the middle
class or working class
but at the same time you know exactly
how it's going to play out because we've
seen it over and over again
i just i'm just i get distracted by her
beauty
and a woman did just walk by anyway
i was like wait i could totally feel uh
jimmy dore not paying attention to what
i'm saying right now well i was looking
at your necklace in the monitor and i
was like that is a nice necklace
thank you jimmy you're the best thank
you that's a call back to the previous
segment which you can probably see below
us
right this second all right last
question on this one what do you think
about if he had just promoted like a
five percent across the board spending
cut for government
employees you know what i mean just a
salary kite and it would have yes of
course there would have been tremendous
brush back on it
but it actually that would have maybe
been a tiny bit of a dent of a number
not just some oh i'm giving twenty
thousand bucks exactly
um i i don't think that that would
actually made a difference as far as the
real
real
difference it would have still been
symbolic but it actually would have hurt
government employees some people who are
government employees i'm i'd be against
that
yeah he already put a freeze he already
did that bs where he put a freeze on
uh raises for government employees right
he did that and so
yeah you know barack obama um i'll just
say that
people say well it's this republicans
they won't let anything happen
they're they're they're blocking
everything he wants to do
well outsmart them what the hell is the
problem
they're not that bright how about trying
out you can't want to does he want to
outsmart them i
i think that that question is the
question that everyone should be asking
obama and the obama administration does
he actually want to increase revenue
i mean does he want to tax the wealthy
like he's pretending like he wants to it
seems
more like he wants to uh make cuts to
social security and medicare well if he
taxed the wealthy anymore they wouldn't
have the 40 000 bucks a plate it costs
to go to one of his fundraisers
and that would not be good he wants to
prove he's a
he's serious and then we all know the
only way you can prove you're serious
is to cut the social safety net from the
people who need it the most the old
and the elderly and the sick yeah all
right well perfect segue because
actually let's uh let's stick with
serious
topics so the plan b pill a judge
ordered that the morning after pill
which is known
as plan b should be available without
prescription
for anyone of any age within uh 30 days
now normally uh it has to be taken
within 72 hours of unprotected sex
there's been all kinds of court cases
about this i think
basically this is pretty good because
women and girls don't want to do this
this is an emergency situation
and of course the right wing is going to
make it seem like oh everyone's going to
have these plan b
parties and they're going to be snorting
those pills popping those pills like
crazy
what do you think i mean do you think
that this is this is just a good thing
and
we shouldn't even be thinking about it i
think that it's a great thing because
you know look teenagers have sex and
everyone likes to like neglect it except
for liberals of course we talk about it
we say like we need to
we need to make sure that they have the
comprehensive sex education we have to
make sure they have access to
contraceptives that's that makes all the
sense in the world
i was really really blown away by the
obama administration last year
when they had made the decision that uh
even though the fda has said that it's
not a health risk
we're going to make sure that anyone
under the age of 17 still needs a
prescription to get their hands on it
how the hell does like a 15 year old or
a 16 year old
get their hands on a prescription within
70 72 hours
so they can get plan b and make sure
they don't get pregnant and especially
in a society where we have so much
guilt related to sex a 15 year old is
most likely not going to her parents to
say i had sex and i got to get a pill
within the next 24 hours
et cetera et cetera so what do you think
well i would when i was young we did my
girlfriend i did plan c which was
horseback riding
so it's a little different but you don't
need a prescription for that no no no
well you do need some sort of license to
get on a horse
no you just show up and give the guy
five bucks pretty sure that's pretty
anyway uh
yeah it sounds crazy that they would no
um somehow somehow terminating a
pregnancy before it starts
is somehow worse than a teenager
actually carrying a pregnancy to term
that doesn't make any sense to me right
it's it's uh it's all backwards i don't
even know the judge had this kind of
power to do this though
the judge said you've got to start
making this available there everyone's
like
can you do that as it is those crazy
activist judges
that's what they always say right it's
an activist judge so
final it's a common sense judge uh it
makes all the sense in the world i'm
glad that he made this ruling
and uh who knows if this is something
that's actually going to
be appealed or anything like that
hopefully not um but
i i and the idea is the conservatives
are afraid that if this is available to
teenagers
that they're going to have more sex
because now they can get rid of their
pregnancy right they're going to
understand
because that's like the coolest thing to
do is get rid of a pregnancy and have an
abortion or take a
plan b which is now what's the do you
know how that works plan b isn't it a
hormone that yes so i if i'm not
mistaking
um what happens is it kind of stops you
from ovulating
um and let's say you're already
ovulating and that
egg uh the sperm goes into the egg
whatever
uh it's yeah what's the correct term of
saying that
fertilizer fertilized thank you i'm like
why am i forgetting this word so the egg
gets fertilized
it does something to the uterus so the
egg cannot implant
itself to the uterus oh sure yeah um so
i think that's the reason why
conservatives have an issue with that
because they see that fertilized egg as
life right moment of conception right so
isn't this one of these things that
should have
nothing to do with government like
shouldn't this be completely
separate from this discussion yes but
what does the government have to do with
this and but yet it automatically is in
the discussion because that's
right people like rick santorum live in
our country right yeah they think that
he even thinks that contraception is bad
that's
it it is wrong it's not right
contraception this is his own words so
we live in a country with religious
crazies and we have to coexist somehow
and
the way we do it is we have good judges
tell them to shut the [ __ ] up that's how
we do it
yeah and we uh push for a legalization
of marijuana which makes us
a little more tolerant of them yes i'm
pushing for it sure
yeah but actually you hit on something
that i want to talk about which is this
idea that
uh the republicans the right wing they
seem to care more
about the fetus than they do once
this child is in the actual thank you
universe
once it's out then then suddenly how
it's going to be paid for or any of that
they don't really care about but they
care about it when it's up in here let
me jump in about this
hypocritical aspect of republicans so
they always say like we care about the
baby we care about the life how could
you get rid of the life
and then they want to cut the same
government programs that would help the
baby
if he or she is born uh to a poor family
right right and a lot of times that's
what happens with women who really
really
don't want to have the baby they want to
get an abortion it's because they know
they don't have the financial stability
to raise the child
and another very recent example was this
representative in arizona
she was testifying about abortion and
she
actually shared her personal story where
she had an abortion
and she's now getting death threats from
pro-life people
because that makes a lot of freaking
sense right you're pro-life but you're
threatening to
kill someone because of a decision that
they made in their life
years ago this has a little westboro
baptist church kind of theme to it
yeah all right we got one more topic but
before we move to it
you'd like this fancy shirt i got uh use
code trr20 at bonobos.com
you can get this shirt they got pants
they got shoes they got backpack
sweaters all kinds of crazy stuff i'm
loving it
you want in on that i sure do t-r-r that
means the
reuben report 2-0 oh my god can i get a
20 discount all right your next purchase
oh
my gosh all right last topic here we go
uh
everyone is getting off television that
addiction of television we are moving
to the addiction of the internet and
you're watching this on the internet so
i guess it's good for us
uh a new belkin and harris interactive
study found that 30
of us internet users are considering
ending their cable plans
um and that by 2014 over 50
of the us internet population will be
watching tv online
and that 40 of all americans by 2014
will be watching tv online
uh yeah are you guys you have a graphic
for this no graphics this week it'd be
nice
those numbers next time let's do it yeah
we'll get pie charts next time
somebody you have a so you have a helper
i we need pie charts i said pie charts
um what do you guys think now i've cut
the cable
i have no uh i'm not on the cable i have
internet
and i have a little roku box and that's
it what about you guys
i i'm still paying for cable but this is
something that i feel bitter about every
month when i get the bill
because i barely watch anything on
television i mean
my guilty pleasure is the real
housewives of whatever city they're
doing that season
um and and i love it because i like to
watch stupid mindless stuff after
talking about stuff like uh i don't know
the grand bargain
at work right right um but i realized
like it's a waste of money
i i'm addicted to netflix i'm now
getting into breaking bad do you guys
watch breaking bad i haven't watched it
oh it's bananas you guys gotta check it
out the comments are going to blow up ow
you don't watch breaking bad
oh it's so good you guys will get
addicted it's okay so it's a show about
meth but
it's that show is like crack for me
i cannot stop watching it wait it's a
show about meth but it's like cracked
it's not like meth to you it's like
cracked wait wait crack
crack cocaine okay sorry i thought it
was getting mixed no no that makes
perfect sense
it's just interesting it's not like meth
to you no that's
like would be a little bit no interest
in the math or the or the crack
but anyway yeah you know
to me scotch is like vicodin that's how
i go yeah
i mean so wheat is like cigarettes
yeah you need a chart for that
drug breakdown chart yes are you
are you hooked on uh the cable i cannot
wait
i cannot you know it's like to me cable
television is like living in russia
right because
you don't you don't get to choose your
cable provider yes
they give it to you and then they don't
give you any customer service they do
they you take it you're hey my internet
went out it's tough pound sand
too bad yeah no one gives it there's no
one to talk to they don't answer the
phone
i have charter i hate them and i can't
even get the channels i want to get but
i couldn't get current tv when they were
still a thing
and uh and so now i i i hate it and i
can't wait
to get rid of cable i can't believe
we're still using the timetable that the
network set up for us like why can't i
just go to abc.com
and watch whatever show i want to watch
at any time of the day well that is
that's now starting like things with
netflix like with house of cards where
they gave you the whole series at once
and you can if you're crazed and you can
watch 24 hours in a row or you can watch
it over a month or whatever
but i get cable for honest to god i get
cable for boxing
because i i could show you you might be
the last guy in america that watches
boxing
i like boxing oh see not like a big
boxing fan like i don't get excited
about uh
fights but if someone's watching it
someone ordered it i'll be like sure
i'll come over
i like nachos the part that i think is
fast
the part that i think is fascinating
about this is we think that monopolies
are just when it's one company that runs
everything but really the cable
companies there's about five big ones
and they've become one monopoly
themselves it's called an oligopoly
right
is it oligopoly yeah so that's basically
what they've become because it's five
companies they sit in a private
boardroom where they negotiate prices so
nobody's giving you anything better
and then they give you 300 channels that
you don't care about and there's nothing
and you have to take them
because you want espn so we're going to
give you 20 other things
right so uh yeah i can't wait to the
bottom line is i can't wait
to get rid of there's a special pit in
hell for the people who run the cable
companies i think yeah so what's keeping
you on it then that's the question
because everyone
this is what everybody's saying now oh i
can get netflix and hbo go and whatever
so what
it's like crack that's like crack i i
like you know i like to be able to
switch around and watch
still television is more convenient than
doing it the other way for me it's much
more convenient i like to i watch new
shows constantly all the time and so i
like to
i don't want to have to go to the and
sometimes they break it up like it is
hard to see some new shows they break it
up too much
and just like how people pay for the tyt
show yeah they want to get it all at
once i like to get it all at once
and so that's how that's why i still
have but i can't wait to where it's
feasible for me to get rid of it plus
it's for the boxing like i said
yeah i got rid of showtime for a little
while and then i missed the whole thing
i was like god damn it i got to get it
back for that boxing
yeah what about just punching a random
person no i don't want to grab i don't
like to fight i like to watch other
people fight want to watch other people
all right well there was very little
fighting here today and this went by uh
nobody got knocked out or injured either
one of you that was
freaking fun that was simple and quick
this is your show this is my show this
is
this seems like a really easy fun show
to do
you just sit down and start talking they
just handed me this and they said talk
that's it all right well i thank anna
caspari and i thank jimmy dore i thank
you guys and
we will be back next week bye
you